القبه الحراريه ستضرب سبع دول عربيه فكيف
ستكون درجات الحراره خلال هذه الايام في
هذه الدول نبدا بالاكثر تاثرا وهو العراق
اذ ستقترب درجات الحراره من الخمسين درجه
مئويه في العاصمه بغداد تليها السعوديه
حيث ستصل درجات الحراره خلال الاسبوع
القادم الى 48 درجه مئويه في العاصمه
الرياض اما في مصر ستصل درجات الحراره
خلال الاسبوع المقبل الى 42 درجه مئويه
وذلك في القاهره في سوريا وتحديدا في دمشق
درجات الحراره الاسبوع المقبل ستصل الى 41
درجه مئويه وفي لبنان وبحسب مصلحه الارصاد
الجويه سوف تلامس درجات الحراره حاجز
الاربعين درجه مئويه كما ترتفع نصب
الرطوبه في المناطق الساحليه ما سيزيد من
الشعور بالحراره وفي الاردن ستصل درجات
الحراره في العاصمه عمان الى 39 درجه
مئويه وتتجاوز ذلك في الاغوار ومحافظه
العقبه وهي اعلى من معدلاته العامه بشكل
واضح
وفلسطين درجات الحراره ستسجل خلال الاسبوع
القادم 36 درجه مئويه والاجواء الاصعب
ستشهدها مناطق الاغوار والبحر الميت حيث
الحراره عند نهايه الاربعينات مئويه اما
في تونس حيث الاجواء حاره حاليا سالنا
الناس كيف تحمي نفسك من حراره الصيف
المرتفعه هذا العام
[موسيقى]
انا والله العظيم معناها نحبو نتقداش واحد
يخدم بالضوء
[موسيقى]
شويه
العرق ههه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات